[Applause]
say what you like about extinction
rebellion thanks partly to them everyone
is now talking about climate change but
what would it actually take to fulfill
their demands
how for instance can we eliminate all
greenhouse gas emissions by 2025 a
quarter of a century before the current
government goal in short and we have to
think of it as a war we're going to have
to suddenly if you like drop our use of
carbon and and do it very quickly
really and at the same time government
is going to have to invest in
alternative systems so people have an
alternative to driving their cars they
can get into buses or into other forms
of public transport but there is an
undercurrent here for many of these
protesters the problem isn't merely
emissions and pollution but economic
growth itself now if you believe there
is a climate crisis there are roughly
two parts you could take first of all
you could say the economy needs to
shrivel up grow less emit less or
secondly you can invest more in Greek
technology grow more and in economic
terms at least have your cake and eat it
according to some entrepreneurs such as
eco tricity founder Dale Vince tackling
climate change doesn't involve enormous
sacrifices
I don't think actually it's an either/or
choice for us I think there's a huge
business opportunity in becoming a zero
carbon country and all we're really
having to do is to change how we do
things so for example in energy we have
to switch from fossil fuel exploration
and burning to using renewable energy
and to make renewable energy we have to
make generators of renewable energy
there's an enormous industrial
opportunity there I think that a focus
only on GDP or only on money is a
mistake
if you focus only on money then you make
bad decisions but it's possible to run a
business in a different way yet even the
most eco conscious business creates a
little bit of pollution along the way
these wind turbines a pot made from
steel and steel production involves
burning coal now that carbon footprint
is paid off with clean energy within
three to six months yet one of the
demands of some climate protesters is to
ban coal mining altogether you see the
problem
it's about the clash of the idealistic
and the realistic in reality things are
moving though ugly not quick enough in
the real world
eliminating emissions doesn't mean you
need to turn the clock back and forget
about growth but if you really want to
go green it helps not to see the world
in black and white at Conway Sky News